Okay, this might be the comfiest thing I have found on TikTok.
At first my husband thought it was a dress,
but it's actually a romper.
It is perfect for chasing kids around,
running errands, doing all that,
but it still has like a feminine feel.
The material is super lightweight and like breathable airy.
Great for warmer weather. But I also think it'd be a cute
like fall transition piece where you could style it for fall.
You could put like a denim coat over it.
My sleeping can probably sleep in this thing.
These shops a lot of times will get out coupons,
so before you buy something
make sure that you look and see if you have any coupons.
Super cute and I love it so far!